una oferta inesperada del primer
ministro polaco varsovia dice estar
dispuesta a transferir toda su flota de
aviones de combate mig 29 a una base
aérea estadounidense en alemania
estamos dispuestos a dar toda nuestra
flota de casas de ramstein pero no
estamos dispuestos a hacer ningún
movimiento por nuestra cuenta
según la propuesta los aviones podrían
ser entregados por eeuu a ucrania
mientras que la fuerza aérea polaca
recibiría aviones de combate f-16 como
reemplazó el secretario de estado
anthony blinken ha dicho que eeuu
estudiará activamente un acuerdo con
polonia para proporcionar a ucrania los
aviones pero a washington parece haberla
agarrado desprevenido el anuncio del
martes
que yo sepa no se ha consultado
previamente con nosotros que planean
darnos estos aviones pero como saben
llevamos un par de días manteniendo
consultas con ellos sobre esta petición
de los ucranianos de recibir sus aviones
posteriormente eeuu rechazo a la oferta
por temor a una escalada del conflicto
mientras que washington ha tratado de
acelerar la entrega de armas de ucrania
el pentágono dijo que la perspectiva de
volar aviones de combate desde el
territorio del otan a la zona de guerra
planteaba serias preocupaciones para
toda la alianza también dijo que
cualquier decisión de transferir aviones
de propiedad polaca dependía de varsovia
ucrania ha incrementado sus peticiones a
los aliados occidentales para que le
suministren aviones militares ante la
invasión rusa pero proporcionará 10
aviones de guerra o campos de aviación
supone graves riesgos y la otan ha
dejado claro en repetidas ocasiones que
no quiere un conflicto directo con moscú